wenn du eine domina tief mit einem
adjektiv umschreiben möchtest musst du
zwei dinge beachten wenn du den
bestimmten artikel nimmt hinter dem
adjektiv ein e wenn du die unbestimmten
artikel nimmt die sendung die änderung
des bestimmten artikels nach und nach
oben
das ist ein grüner schwamm das ist der
grüne schwamm
das ist ein bunter tetra pak das ist der
hunte tetra pak das wird eine scharfe
schere das ist die scharfe schere
das ist ein spannendes buch das ist das
spannende buch das sind weiße
taschentücher
das sind die weichen taschentücher da
wird ein grauer weg hab das ist der
graue wecker da wird ein leckeres obama
das ist das leckere huber um das ist ein
weißes taschentuch das ist das
taschentuch das ist ein großer
müllbeutel das ist der große müllbeutel
das wirft ein brauner kaffeefilter dass
der braune kaffeefilter das ist ein
dreckiger staub fischer das ist der
dreckige staub fischer das ist eine
schöne kerze das ist die schöne kerze
das ist eine volle schachtel das ist die
volle schachtel
das ist ein leerer teller
das ist der leere teller das ist ein
blauer beute
das ist der blaue beutel da hilft ein
roter stift das ist der rote stift das
ist ein polnisches bier das ist das
polnische wir da wird eine recycelbare
flasche das ist die recycelbare fasse
das sind gute kopfhörer das sind die
guten kopfhörer
[Musik]